alo alo
anh Alo ạ
alo
nghĩ hỏng kiểu tự nhiên giờ không kết
nối được với con à Mày tính nữa nên là
bây giờ tôi đang dùng con tai nghe kết
hợp với Mike là
cái con tai nghe tôi bảo con cái này
ngoài con đi
tra xem con tai nghe đâu nhé ra nó về Hà
Nội Computer
Cái con này này này là con đang nghe từ
công ty tôi công ty tôi tặng gọi là công
ty tôi mua cả già máy tính cho anh em ấy
có có cả con tai nghe này
mua Hà Nội dạy mà công
nghệ sĩ Phải chăng đây Con con ạ Alo 400
đã hết
Anh ơi sao
hình như con này
anh
đợi tôi đang xem con hả
Bây giờ không bán nữa nhỉ Nó có mic chỗ
nào Chỉ cần vài trăm thôi như con này
bốn trăm thật đấy nó có cả mic chồng
không đẹp nha con nào nhỉ 2
các bạn nữa lại phải đấy con này Đấy là
giờ nó có cả mic nhưng mà nó không thực
sự là
nó không chuyên rồi một cái không hi
vọng được là nó sẽ chị không ạ Không
nghe rõ mà alo alo nghe ổn đúng không
Không bị lỗi cậu
có bị bé của ông nó bé quá Tôi sẽ thường
chưa nói to
bé đúng không làm sao tính ra tôi một
con người hơi bị ngược một tí tôi
Hà bị rè anh về thì à anh nghe tôi tôi
vừa nói đấy con tai nghe này nó rẻ tiền
đấy là thực ra là
nên là không kiểu dạng là không Xịn về
cái khoản thu âm nó đâu phải chịu thôi
con
vì thực ra tôi là con người à Ăn bé nói
to
không ạ ăn to nói lớn đấy thì ngược lại
là ăn Ăn bé nói lớn từ thế với ăn chọn
kiểu hỏi chậm Nhưng chúng tôi nhai kĩ
cái được là tôi không hẳn là một người
thăm ăn nhiều lắm nhưng mà tôi được cái
mồm Kha to ngày ra là
tôi có thể hoàn toàn bạn luôn coi được
Thậm chí tôi dậy ở trên trên lớp như dạy
trên lớp thì không cần phải dùng mic hay
gì cả nhưng mà anh nói cho bạn là tôi
từng nói rất to ở trong khó khăn hát bài
không cần mic đây là tôi tự tin là tôi
có thể nói to được con Lê khoản nó trong
vòng 2 tiếng thì cũng biết là tôi sợ ồn
ảnh hưởng người khác rồi tôi đóng cái
cửa đợi công ty à
ok Nói chung là tranh thủ mình tâm sự
một tí hôm trước chưa tâm sự mấy thì hôm
nay có tâm sự rất nhiều
rất nhiều cảm xúc kiểu cả buồn vui đùa
cả tôi sẽ cho ông xem cái này đầu tiên
đã
[âm nhạc]
Ừ cái này tôi thấy rất là hai kiểu Đây
là cậu lớp tiểu học và tôi nhớ là hồi mà
tôi đã xem không biết là bây giờ thay
đổi không đó là bên Nhật bên nhập thì à
tiểu học lớp 1 lớp 2 lớp 3 gì vậy và
không thi cử gì cả họ sẽ học cái gì họ
sẽ học à lịch sử văn hóa các thứ thứ của
Nhật
nói chung là kiểu văn hóa dân tộc chứ
không phải là học kiểu dạng là thế là
cũng học chữ viết nhưng mà không học các
môn Toán học cái gì đó kiểu phức tạp cả
học rất đơn giản bạn trai thi cử thì cả
khá là dạy cho người ta có lòng tự tôn
ông ấy ông ấy thì thế tự học sự tiểu học
bây giờ bảo mấy ông nhớ được là mấy ông
đã học những cái gì mà còn đã thi Bởi vì
nếu mà chả nhớ ông làm gì qua môn làm
sao được điểm cao như thế đúng không ạ
Cứ ngờ Ừ để học cộng trừ nhân chia thì
có vẫn còn nhớ đến bây giờ thì vẫn nhớ
nhưng mà
sự thì
đối với tôi con điểm ấy Tôi không biết
từng nói với ông chưa
rồi Tôi ôm lấy tôi con Điệp kìa tôi sẽ
không hướng đến con của tôi về sau giỏi
con có thể là mình có thể ra gì đấy có
thể về cho mình ra gì Yêu cầu là người
người có địa vị người có tiếng nói vẫn
vật mình gọi là cứ thành công đi Nếu tôi
ở không mong con của mình về sau là một
con người cậu thành công nối nghiệp mình
ai gì đó tôi chỉ muốn con mình kiểu đúng
nghĩa là nên người theo các loại biết
ứng nhân xử thế nóng và không biết cách
cư xử được đọc nó đến chết
sẽ Thả nào tôi sẽ phải
dạy nó cách cư xử với người khác đối xử
với tất cả mọi người
ai biết cách nói chuyện Nói chung nhà ở
Nói chung là không hẳn là giả tạo tôi ra
Tôi rất ghét luôn người tạo ở chung nhà
mình mình thì à
a nhôm cái tắt của mình đối tốt không
hiểu biết đúng sai không ạ còn tốt hơn
chắc là tôi sẽ tôn trọng nó kiểu là nó
muốn gì Nó đã phân biệt đúng sai rồi nó
muốn vì để việc của nó mình không cản gì
cả nhưng mà còn à cách kiểu Dạ
không tôi không quan tâm với việc nó
không hàng như thế nào
đấy quà trong trong cái video này thì
thầy đang dạy cho học sinh cách kiểu
kiểu giả chỉ nói đơn giản một câu thôi
con yêu mẹ đúng không ạ Đấy đã bao lần
bao lâu rồi Mấy ông chưa nói những cái
đấy bố mẹ của mình ạ lần gần đây nhất
tôi đi tham gia cũng đi đa cấp người ta
cũng yêu cầu bỏ tôi gọi điện cho bố mẹ
chúng mày nói cái này xong rồi mở nhạc
kiểu Mở nhạc của xin tất cả đơn lên đấy
nhạc rất là buồn xong rồi à Ừ ai cũng
khóc hay cười thế thì khi mà người ta
động và lòng trắc ẩn Kiểu cái lòng trắc
ẩn của ông thì ông dễ nghe hơn ông vợ
trong lúc người ông cảm xúc dâng trào ấy
bị nhớ hơn sẽ nhớ những điều người ta
nói đấy
cách tán gái cũng như thế đấy cầm dài sẽ
nhớ những gì ông đã làm chứ Nhớ những gì
ông đã làm cho họ cảm thấy chứ không nhớ
những gì ông đã làm đâu đấy Ông có thể
là cây rất nhiều cái sai lầm rất nhiều
lỗi lầm về mặt lô rách thì nó sai hoàn
toàn nhưng con gái thì ra không nghĩ
không nghĩ về lôgic mấy Dạ không nhớ
những điều đấy mà 13 nhớ cảm xúc của ông
đẹp lại người ta nên là ông mà làm được
người ta có rất nhiều cảm xúc lần gần
đây nhất tôi đi hẹn hò
tôi chẳng ở xa tôi à
không hiểu hôm đấy là nói chuyện về có
dính vào da các
bạn đấy à Tốt nhất là ngồi nói chuyện đã
khóc cơ tôi không kiếm lại khóc nha Trả
qua nói chuyện gia đình bạn nhớ bố mẹ và
khóc và sau lần ấy bạn rất ấn tượng với
tôi bởi vì à Kiểu khi mà có quá nhiều
cảm xúc rồi Họ sẽ nhớ mình hơn
đấy Đấy là lý do mà tôi dậy cho mấy ông
đổi từng ngày tâm sự Tôi muốn cho gần
gũi mời ông bà có những cái cảm xúc như
thế này nữa thì bé ông sẽ nhớ được toàn
bộ những cái thứ hơn khi mà ông đã có
cảm xung kiểu gọi là hâm nóng hâm nóng
gọi kiểu thế
thì ông sẽ cảm xúc hơn thay vì tôi dạy
cho ông đeo đeo đeo cái giọng đều đều
thì ông sẽ đỡ buồn ngủ vào không nhớ gì
cả ông khéo một bộ phim hay là bộ phim
cậu có gây gây cho ông cảm xúc
ạ tình cảm ông có tình cảm với tội được
và tình cảm kiểu muốn về chung nhà được
ở nhà tôi không đủ chỗ đâu ạ đề
thi ở ba cái video này tôi hãy Thế hai
điểm nữa đó là em bé này những người lớn
Mình thực ra rất khó nói rồi Tại sao thì
mình có cái tôi Nhưng mà Mấy ông đấy kỹ
Mấy em kia thì đang đùa cười có thể mà
em kia chưa bị gọi lên kiểu ngày hoặc là
gọi rồi nhưng mà thấy ra bình thường
kiểu trẻ con mình nói cái từ yêu bố mẹ
rất là bình thường đúng ạ
nhưng mà gái em này thì khác em hãy đã
cảm thấy mấy cái từ đấy giờ tương đương
và quan trọng rồi em phải nói rõ là thật
lòng đúng không ạ và kiểu
kịch kể Tôi thích kiểu con người như này
trở dạ nhà người ta thấy bật khóc nhưng
mà nó một cái gì đó mang phía con trai
nhưng mà thực ra là tôi từng nói đó là
có người mạnh không phải là người không
không bao giờ khóc mà người mạnh là
người có rất nhiều cảm xúc rất nhiều cảm
xúc Đấy và cảm xúc họ rất là mạnh ấy Đấy
đấy là người mạnh họ sẽ hiểu
Khi mà họ đã muốn làm cái gì họ sẽ làm
những cái điều rất to lớn còn nếu mà ông
mà con người mà hơi bị vô cảm một tí thì
thực ra là làm gì đó nó hơi hồi hộp nó
không được à mãnh liệt những người kia
đâu tại nè thức mà mình cũng
mình cũng khác rất nhiều loài là mình có
nhiều cảm xúc hơn bọn nó rất nhiều loài
loài mực thấp thì nó họ thì bản thân não
của nó sẽ không có nhiều cảm xúc phức
tạp được như con người không khó hiểu
như con gái nữa
đây
đây tiện thì cũng nói qua với những cái
lời khuyên đưa mấy ông này khi
gà Tôi bảo là buồn tâm sự tôi thương anh
có tí lên lên lớp thì vậy dạy về
kiểu bài toán Con người hơn như là ông
nào Muốn nghe thì nghe không ạ Không thì
đội và người tâm sự tôi sẽ dạy học
thì cái á
Nó bảo this code anh còn thông báo về
chứ và không thông báo vào cái kênh nha
anh có thuốc báo này anh không thông báo
vào cái kênh
school thôi Bởi vì a cool thì à Anh
thường ấy thông báo liên quan đến kiểu
về đồ án hơn
Nói chung là mấy ông ấy chả mở thông báo
ở trên kênh YouTube của tôi là tốt nhất
để tôi đang cái gì mày không nhận được
hoặc là cứ đến giờ đúng giờ là vào thôi
đúng không ạ Thì giờ nó vẫn cố định trừ
khi là có lịch gì đâu xuất tôi sẽ thông
báo cụ thể sau thì à anh ở đây thì
khứ này thì à
thông báo cho nào mà họ khi anh vẫn
thông báo đây mà anh không thông báo và
bảo kênh server của mình đâu
không Tôi không cần mấy online nhưng mà
Mấy ông có thể mở thông báo cũng không
cần phải xuất ngoại Speed thì mày có mở
được bán được nghỉ nhưng đại khái là tôi
thấy là thận 9.000 người theo dõi rồi
cùng đi Tôi ra thấy con số mà nhiều quá
như thế không thích Vì thực tế lại ít
Tôi không cần số lượng với cần cẩu thực
tế ấy
cũng có dự định về sau lên FPT Dậy Mà nè
Ừ anh đây một cơ hội tốt thậm chí ở ngày
mai anh cũng đi một buổi cà phê lên FPT
FPT không ở Hòa Lạc mà là ở cái cơ sở
mới để mà anh anh anh ở bên sshop anh ấy
sẽ trao đổi với anh một vài thứ nữa đây
cũng là đầu anh và mang đấy và nói chung
là tạo mối quan hệ thôi à đây Thì đang
nói giờ thì cái thay đổi sau quá khứ này
Hôm trước có một bạn bạn đấy cứ tự ti Bà
cứ bảo với tôi à Bạn không phòng của em
kiếm được nửa tỷ 1 tháng
ở đâu 01 tháng Nói chung kiếm một nửa tỷ
rồi Cái đấy thì em cảm thấy hiểu bản
thân mình chưa là cái gì cả và lần đấy
thì bạn đang rất tự ti thì lúc đấy thôi
thì nói đó là nếu không mở được phép nên
so sánh mình với bất kỳ ai cả
cờ tướng gia là tuy nhiên ở chúng ta nên
biết mình biết ta biết được nữa ta biết
mình thì em chỉ ở mình sẽ biết được cái
Mọi người như thế nào để mình phấn đấu
hay là để mình nhìn vào để mà tránh gì
đó tôi thường ai bảo nhìn vào để tránh
cá sấu Họ được cái học hỏi và trải như
thế người cho anh những cái quan trọng
đó là có thêm đỡ đầu là ông Đừng so sánh
mình với bất kỳ người nào xong mình giỏi
hơn người làm Mỗi người đều có một ưu
nhược điểm của họ ông làm sao không thể
so sánh tất cả vừa giống nhau rồi đúng
không ạ Đấy thì đấy kém nhất bởi vì rất
là hoàn cảnh và xuất phát của của hai
người khác nhau mà đúng ạ
sữa chua hai người khác nhau đúng không
ạ Cái cả hai anh em sinh đôi được ra còn
Chắc còn chả vừa giống nhau được 100 tại
sao mình lại đi sao tháng mình ôm người
khác
thêm mình so sánh về ai bây giờ đi sang
với chính mình trong quá khứ thế là được
ứng dụng của tôi luôn tự tin và tôi tốt
hơn sau cả thứ tôi buốt trẻ trâu hơn vào
quá khứ cho dù tôi vẫn phải cho có chấm
nguồn tôi vẫn luôn là tôi đang bớt trẻ
trâu hơn bạn hơn tôi 5 phút trước cảm
thấy mình tĩnh tiễn 5 phút trước để chạy
sau Bây giờ thì đỡ hơn cả thế
tôi luôn luôn so sánh mình quá khứ Nếu
mấy ông quen tôi từ bây giờ bây giờ ấy
thôi với ông xem lại cái video đầu tiên
của tôi dậy vào 6 tháng trước ông sẽ
thấy cách nói chuyện của tôi khác rất
rất nhiều đấy thì mấy ông sẽ thấy da tôi
thay đổi rất nhiều
ông bây giờ để nửa năm nữa bị ông thấy
tôi lại cách nói chuyện rất là khác đâu
có tự tin là tôi đang tốt hơn sau quá
khứ liên tục
nên là mấy ông cũng nên cậu như thế Đạt
cột mốc là chính bản thân anh không so
sánh mình vì ai cả Không ạ
tiếp theo bà
ờ ai có khuyết điểm của họ đúng ạ thích
cái cái ở đây là ông có ông còn nên tự
ti với khuyết điểm của mình không thì là
tôi là tôi không tự ti khuyết điểm tôi
lắm đâu có một vài cái đúng sự thật nếu
mà vài cái gì tôi đi nghĩ là tôi cải
thiện được thì không tự đi lắm
Tôi sẽ biến nữa vài cái ưu điểm của tôi
khắc phục Google cửa Tôi không
việc nhà không biết làm ăn các bạn tới
Thượng Cũng khắc phục của tôi Cậu tập
trung là thứ gì tôi giỏi đó Kiếm tiền
làm làm những cái thứ mất rồi đam mê này
kiếm được cho về sau có thể thuê giúp
việc mà mua máy rửa bát hay gì đó Mày
nấu ăn này không có cho đi câu được một
là kiếm vợ hai đã kiểm duyệt Ở đây Ờ
Ừ tôi có khuyết điểm đã nói nhiều Cái
này ra tôi sẽ cải thiện bằng cách à Nói
nói chuyện à Cố nói những cái chủ đề mà
người khác muốn nghe mà nghe được gì ấy
mà biết cách nói người ta đỡ bất hủ và
Vân đấy Thì
đấy là một trong những cách mà tôi đang
nói theo góc nhìn của tôi nó cải thiện
có phải cái thể hiện được chứ mấy ông
đừng có tự tin quá nhiều và cư trăm mà
những khuyết điểm của bản thân ai mà có
khuyết điểm ạ
ở chùa tính tôi là không Không nên tự
tin chúng ta tự tin nếu mà tự tin ở đây
không phải là tự ti nữa cửa
cố chấp bảo thủ Quá không ạ thì mình
không Họ học hỏi được thêm cái gì
nói nhiều nó khuyết điểm cho em nói
nhiều mà thực sự mà nói trá mà không ai
nghe thì chẳng ai muốn ở gần mình cả
thấy ghét nhất thứ hai là thực ra là nói
nhiều nó không không bằng nghe nhiều
biết lắng nghe biết lắng nghe nhá chứ
không phải là ông ngồi nhưng mà không
nói gì và cũng đầu mối phía bắc cái thứ
thì người ta cũng không ăn ở muốn nói
chuyện với ông đâu nhưng mà ông Biết
khơi gợi câu chuyện để người ta tin
tưởng người ta nói chuyện với ông và ông
học hỏi được rất nhiều một nói bằng hai
nhẹ nhàng nhập một nghe và hay nói được
là được cả là ông học hỏi được nhiều hơn
khi mà nghe này ra cũng phải khi bỗng
nói đúng không ạ Đấy cái hợp được là
người ta sẽ cảm thấy thân với ông hơn
anh nói được giải tỏa được hết
kiểu tâm sự một bịch người ta cho ông
rồi chẳng hạn thì anh sẽ nhớ ông hơn này
nhé thật nhưng mà ông vẫn phải học cách
lắng nghe Có phải học nhá Cái này thì
vẫn này học chứ không phải là không
không Cứ ngồi vắt người ta sẽ kể hết đâu
em ạ này Đấy ông kia đang bảo trả lời cứ
ừ thì đương nhiên là sẽ trả nó không ạ
thì người ta không vẫn cái đấy không hỏi
Hàn gọi là biết lắng nghe đâu đấy Có rất
nhiều mẹo để mà hồi trưa Tôi đọc cái và
là đôi khi ông chỉ cần nói lại câu cô ấy
mày ra nói thêm 1 vài thứ tư nữa ngồi
nó bỏ đi thật à ấy gió
xe tải kèo thế chẳng ăn thế thì người ta
bấm lời người ta nói tiếp tưởng hết cái
khó nhá Thôi không điện được rồi đấy
tiếp theo đó là
cái bài trên qua tôi từng nói nhóm này
khá ổn theo kiểu diễn dịch ra Nhưng mà
từ ra đôi khi là nó hơi bị định hướng sự
định hướng là định hướng thông tin tí dư
luận rất là sao nghĩa là cái nồi nói cái
câu trả lời trong bài này chưa chắc nó
đã là một câu trả lời chuột mà Nó kiểu
nó cung cấp rất nhiều thông tin thì có
thể là không hẳn mà không hẳn là thông
tin sai nhưng rồi chú mà nó thông tin
một chiều về một cái ví dụ Giả sử hôm
trước đây Đang thông tin về
chính trị ạ một vấn đề rất nhạy cảm thì
ông mà chỉ đăng thông tin về một chiều
thì ra thấy không tốt thì thế nhớ mà còn
mày này thì hai bài này nó về à Đó là
kiểu tín nhiệm về viết tivi và cái bài
này bình luận cũng rất là hay bình luận
cũng kiểu chia sẻ thêm rất nhiều cái mẹo
nữa đầu tiên đừng để địa chỉ nhà riêng
trên tivi tội tiếng nói vụ này rồi không
ạ tiếp theo đó là ờ ờ
cho biết dịch từ đoạn này như thế nào
nếu hai điểm bạn thấp quá đừng nên ghi
và seri gà tôi tôi không không thích mày
ông ghi bằng cấp ở trong tivi tranh để
làm gì ông khoe này cái khác này ra quan
tâm người khác hơn dai so 10 CV ở định
dạng PDF bởi vì là nữa word thì thì nó
lỗi phone Nếu là sử cái gì đó nên dùng
bf2 tôi chưa nói nhưng mà thường là tài
mấy cái trang online nó toàn nào về để
ép hết tiếp theo
đó là mấy ông liệt kê trong thôi kính
hiệu đấy thì mày ông Đức à Ừ thì cụ thể
hơn đừng nói chung chung là hỗ trợ khách
hàng mà hỗ trợ cụ 60 khách hàng một ngày
mà gà vẫn chưa hiểu
Nói chung là tạo được phần mềm mà hỗ trợ
được cho hàng triệu người dùng trong
vòng một ngày chẳng hạn như thế thì đó
kiểu có cái những cái con số thêm ấy thì
nó sẽ có vẻ ổn bị tín hơn ấy
viết thêm rõ thời điểm tốt nghiệp này
cho mấy ông đang còn là sinh viên này
không ạ thì thay vì kiểu đến hiện tại
không thể đoán được là bao nhiêu bao
nhiêu lâu tốt nghiệp ra có sang vài
trang Tivi Nó đang kiểu nó có tích vào
là lại vẫn đang học thì vẫn đang làm đấy
thế là nó đến nay thành ra thực là tôi
không thích Hồi trước có cái Trang nó là
kiểu cho Bấm cho mất thời gian tôi thích
cái đấy hơn tiếp theo là đầy đủ họ tên
ở
đây Cái này làm chỉ là khi mà đặt tên
cho cái file thì lên là đầy đủ họ tên
chứ không phải là tên là Siri và cho vào
cách tôi đặt tên đấy thường là tôi sẽ
đặt tên cho kiểu như thế này gà một phần
là tên của tôi thì có thể không không bị
nhầm được
tôi sẽ tên kiểu này Nguyễn Nam Long cảnh
ngay
pdf nào ạ chuyện với ai đó thì cái tên
kiểu này không có dấu thì vẫn không sao
gà mày ra không nên được gọi tên file Có
dấu làm gì không ạ Nếu mà vài bạn để tên
là không có dấu có thể nhầm tên thật à
từ
không cần viết thư giới thiệu làm gì và
không cần đấy
xem
tivi nên gói gọn cho một trang giấy này
web 2.0
hôm trước tôi đọc coi ở đấy đợi tròn
hiệu USB 3.0 cái gì cả
dùng để có buổi phỏng vấn không phải để
có công việc tôi thấy câu này rất là hay
Nghĩa là nghĩa làm chị là ông trịch có
xin đi thì nói chỗ nào đến mức tương đối
để người ta cảm thấy cũng có tính tò mò
thêm với ông chở loạn và cảm thấy ông có
vẻ Ôi để mà cân nhắc là kiểu sẽ phỏng
vấn ông nên là cũng đừng chém gió quá
trong cái phí bi để cho người ta khi
phỏng vấn với ra đuổi ông đấy
girl mà tôi tạo ra nhóm gái xinh chọn
lọc cái gì ạ Con nhóm dưới hay girl à
quanh Mạnh Tuấn ở công ty đóng cửa à
anh
alo ờ
có đây chắc là những cái tâm sự này cho
để buổi sau đi được xanh xanh giờ với sự
phép chia sẻ nốt cái này đó là cái có
bạn hôm trước chính xác là có một kênh
hôm trước tôi xem anh đấy giới thiệu có
cái Trang cũng khá 32 trang đấy Tổng hợp
một loạt các phần mềm kiểu dạng là cũng
được Hay nhiều người dùng sau đó đi ỉa
tích tích tích hết vào giờ ấn nút loa Em
tải phần mềm những bản cái đào tất cả
những phần mềm này cũng một lúc đấy ra
là hay Nhưng mà tôi thấy có người bảo là
Trang đấy không không đầy đủ những cái
phiên bản mới nhất thì nếu mà muốn có
những phiên bản mới nhất thì tôi nghĩ là
cái trạng thái phần mềm này tôi đã từng
dùng từ rất là lâu rồi tôi biết cái phần
mềm này chắc là từ hồi à
cấp 3 với cấp 3 của tôi rất là lâu rồi
vẫn me gì nó cũng là tổng hợp tất cả
những cái phần mềm Chắc là chủ yếu là
miễn phí chủ yếu miễn phí ở trên này và
ông có thể tải toàn bộ những cái phiên
bản nó luôn là mới nhất là thực ra có
thể thêm nhiều cái nữa hả Tôi đang mở
chặn con cá rồi đúng không
thằng này nó sẽ không luôn nó không nó
không dính thêm bất kì cái gì của virus
hay cái gì cả ông chứ không phải ở trên
này mấy ông hiểu không và nó không dính
thêm bất kỳ phần mềm con nào cả ấy rất
tiện nói chung là lên đây hợp và hồi đấy
à Hồi đấy là do làm mấy cái phần mềm này
nó còn chưa Mập định là tự động tự động
cập nhật cơ thì phần mềm này nó còn tìm
tìm kiếm hộ cho ông kiểm tra hộ ông
những phần mềm nào Đang nhà đang kiểu
Đăng phiên bản cũ với nó cầm để thu âm
cơ đấy Cái phần mềm này một phần ra hai
giúp Winslet này chẳng hạn visa phải nó
không thường xuyên kiểm tra cập nhật đâu
ai
ông thể tải về xem cái này thì tải hỗ
trợ tài bá0 vẽ hỗ trợ Tải driver cho gần
đây Nói chung là tôi bị thì tôi bị lỗi
driver về con Mic Mic không nhận và tôi
cũng không muốn thử các phần mềm Tải
driver nó kiểu 50 50 cái gì Ừ
này Hôm trước vẫn chưa hỏi trả lời xong
thôi tôi sẽ trả lời câu hộ câu này vậy
hôm trước thì tôi có thực ra tôi có cho
mày không xem rồi Nó lại năm hết
Im
spo trở lại
đây thì
sẽ có khái niệm là kiểu
cái Trang mà
ở đây nó khái niệm mà còn những cách lưu
vào như thế nào nếu mà thay bồ với 50
thì ông sẽ phải lưu lại rất nhiều cái ở
đây như thế này không ạ Có bao nhiêu cái
ông sẽ xảy ra trong như lại thêm nếu heo
này Vodka kiểu dạng cho người dùng tiền
thì công a tiếp theo với cho in in là
mình sẽ tự Tuy gốc số nó là gì ngọn từng
cái đấy số nó gì đấy
tiếp theo là à Kiểu này mình sẽ mình sẽ
phải quý gốc cái số này do về cái bảng
Bảng này đấy lấy đầy ra được tên của cái
tên cái đấy Và đây là trong trường hợp
là 1,5 triệu cái gì à
em
về Để em nhé
Đây là 1,5 triệu vi code và có 29 cái
thằng test này Ok thử xem nhé Kết quả
cho với khi mà chạy câu truy vấn đấy thì
nó sẽ không phải 008 cái này cũng tương
tự với 3 tra thì ông sẽ thấy thực ra với
cái thằng Y Nam mình đã làm xong trước
đây cả ạ và cái thằng choi thì ra nó trả
lời gì cả Không ạ dành cho trận nhé Cho
lời cả bởi vì về các bà tội giọng nói đó
là thằng cho thằng đối với thằng Acquy
thì cho roi nó cũng hỗ trợ Khá mẹ nó
không bị khô nhăn bị chậm lắm đấy
sự mà
order bye cái gì đó như này thì mới ông
sẽ thấy là anh vẫn là tốc độ năm thì
nhanh nhất năm bởi vì bản thân là thần y
nam này chắc là đối về equal nó sẽ là sẽ
vẫn là một cái danh sách gì đó còn nhanh
hơn hẳn qua trai đấy bà cuối cùng cho
chậm nhất rồi lên 26 giây ông ạ ấy rồi
mấy ông thể xem khái niệm Ace Plan trees
của nó nữa Tại sao như thế
mà kết quả cuối cùng là
cái gì đây đây là offset Bỏ qua Bỏ qua
10.000 để lấy 5 thằng thằng nào bật
nhanh hơn đồng ra rồi nhưng mà thằng này
thì
vẫn chậm hơn tí ơi Ok
thời
tí hon Ông hỏi tôi đấy
Ôi tôi hướng mấy ông thực ra không Đừng
có đoán hay mày tôi không Tôi không
hướng để mấy ông làm cái gì ở công nghệ
giữa chị mà tôi hướng đến mấy ông có
những cái bài toán liên quan nghiệp vụ
có cần xử lý cái bài văn nghĩa vụ chứ
không phải là một bài toán mà có rất
nhiều cái tính năng chị sò trong đấy bởi
vì chị xong như thế mà chất là ông ôm
công nghệ về chưa Ông không hình dung
được là là cái bài toán có tình huống
nào mình giải quyết nha kết hợp với ít
câu truy vấn đã ra tay thì sẽ càng không
thích tôi muốn bà ngoại còn rất nhiều
thì ông làm quen việc Ở đây có thử đã
thì sao ghét cho nữa vẫn là người yêu cũ
thôi Đây tiện thì có bạn à
Hôm trước bà ấy bảo tôi là mấy cái
f-stop của tôi thì
đợi tí hai Mẹ ơi chuyện gì khác à pp tôm
của tôi thì nó nó còn hiển thị ra kiểu
như này Nếu không thấy không có thêm là
kiểu kiểu mình chuyên cài á truyền cái
gì vào trong cái cái
hàm này nó sẽ hiểu gợi ý dai thứ thử thì
thằng Viết cốt nó có cái tương tự không
cái
thì nói chung là mày ông tôi chắc là bể
mấy ông Tự bình luận nha Tôi không dùng
vé cốt thì ông sẽ tự bình luận là những
tiện ích Viết cốt với ông dụng hoặc là
mấy ông thì bình luận không bình luận
trong này bị trôi thì mấy ông lên Ít
code với mấy ông bình luận nha tổng hợp
mà chung nhà lên đi con lên server với
cô tin
tổng hợp lại các thứ thứ đấy
Ở đây nó có thể chơi đấy
ấy
Ok chưa
nhé
em
nói kệ đi
bây giờ hôm nay mình sẽ cái vụ sắp xếp
rồi nhóm đồ án thì tội làm xong rồi ra
để tí tôi có vài nhóm với nhiều trước
tôi chưa kết nối được mài nhọn mười mấy
bạn đấy thì mấy bạn đấy để ai đi nó hơi
bị có bạn còn để ai đi theo kiểu đúng
mỗi số làm sau t thôi đâu Mấy tội ác dặn
rồi mày ông phải mà một nick ở đây này
để copy ra và cặp tên và cả cả ID như
này người tên là mấy ông trùm nhau với
tôi sẽ tra được theo ID đấy hoặc là mấy
ông ghi Võ hoàn toàn bộ nó là số ID được
cái ông trao Google nó ra bye bye mai
và Mai discord hay đi dạo nhãn Mình ở
Dân công nghệ mà cái gì mình cũng lên
tra Google đã nóng ạ
nhưng mà hôm trước có bạn để vài số lính
ta tinh các thứ tôi chả tìm được Ừ tôi
cũng không nghe không chắc là béo không
phải chủ động để mà
nhắn tin Facebook cho mấy bạn đấy hòa
bình luận hoặc là tí thôi sẽ để lại
email mày ông gửi nữa chứ Tôi đã từng
gửi cho mấy bạn đấy thôi Hình như tôi bị
cho và span rồi đấy Gần đây tôi gửi bốn
mươi mấy bạn nhưng mà có mỗi một hai bạn
trả lời thôi có nghĩa bị vào thư mục
giác mong chờ
hình của thằng level tế là nó khác với
mồi VC ở một chỗ này đây
mới C ô tô cho bé uống xe à
nó có thêm cái gì nó nó không phải đơn
giản và mpc kiểu ngày nữa có thêm một
cái đó chính là này rất thích hình này
thì ngày để bây giờ vẫn đúng chùa Từ 5.8
gì nó bản chất nó vẫn đúng nó là cái gì
đó là khi mà người dùng sẽ gọi đến cái
đường link của mình cái ô tô đúng ạ thì
nó sẽ thông quan mới được nghe ông nhìn
thấy đề hình của ông bảo vệ không ạ kiểu
cảnh sát từ cái gì đó spell it is an
ninh đúng không
Thì đây bizweb này Nó sẽ chặn nó sẽ chặn
và nó sẽ luôn kiểm tra vé vào cửa quyền
truy cập các thứ thứ để tiếp để mà có
thể nhảy vào những thời tiết heo đấy thì
hôm nay mình sẽ kết hợp với việc là mình
học cái đăng nhập thí sinh đấy những kết
hợp với cái á nhí từ Where để mà kiểm
tra nếu trông thấy rõ ràng là hồi đồ án
một đấy thì mình phải cố học cái shit
khi đăng nhập trước để làm gì Để và với
mọi file mình phải chèn thêm một cái
đoạn gliwice kiểm tra cái file là
đã đăng nhập Thấy chưa đúng ạ Còn không
bây giờ thì làm mô mình hình mvc là ông
thích cốt để đi trước cũng được với ông
cốc thế này sao cũng được Ông chị Tống
nó vào một cái chỗ riêng và toàn bộ
trọng khác là vẫn chạy lại rất là ngon
tôi sẽ đưa tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông
ờ ờ
bây giờ đầu tiên là đầu tiên là mình sẽ
phải tạo một cái á Ở
ở đầu tiên là bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một
bản để đăng nhập không ạ
I
được
à à
chưa hình dung với bạn lắm
à
chưa Tôi chưa dùng cái Battle CMS kia à
ca ifish
Ừ
đợi tao tí tôi phải tạo lại cái này hình
như nó vừa đăng suốt ra cho
anh
em restore ngày mấy ông nên dùng merdu
tội không có kia không
cho
but the way vẫn được không Thế thì sai
mà bản chất rồi bạn vì rõ ràng là mình
tại sao mình vẫn để cho vô xử lý khi mặt
người ấy không Quyền truy cập nhỉ Mình
phải từ chỗ luôn chứ đừng từ chối để cho
đỡ nặng cho vô xử lý mình có đoạn làm
sau chứ chứ
em lấy thế bị ngược ấy nghĩ the weather
đây đây theo hình ảnh biết được nghe
rằng ai phải là thằng trước xe đấy Còn
bạn làm kiểu thế bị ngược với rồi rõ làm
middleware nó phải luôn kiểm tra quyền
trước trước khi mà thao tác một cái gì
đó thì đây mới chuẩn của cái lý thuyết
của thằng nghĩ được em ạ
Ê
mấy ông sẽ thấy là à đầu tiên là bây giờ
mình sẽ tạo à
thì mình sẽ tạo bằng cốc ngọn mình sẽ
tạo bằng cốt để mà tạo bảng ozer chẳng
hạn để đăng nhập lại không ạ
khi sex
Ừ
tôi lại ra vài cái tục
Ê
tôi dậy mày ông sẽ có khá nhiều cái đây
Ở đây có vài cái dậy rồi
Xuân sau nóng này dậy này
a cho tôi chưa biết the weather
the weather sáng hẳn à
đồng này có phải cái ông thấy đốt quà
tôi đã dậy rồi đấy ok
học phân quyền thì tôi sẽ tôi bảo tôi
chưa dùng cái Pocket L'Oreal
market nhập Maria permission thì tôi sẽ
tìm hiểu cái đấy lẫn cả vai Âu nữa thì
đợi theo tìm hiểu đấy tôi sẽ dậy người
đứng sau còn bây giờ thì ra là mình có
thể dùng chứ sân với a midway vẫn được Ừ
không sao cả à
ở
tp attention and make a
their table chẳng hạn
Anh
không dùng Pocket có được không ạ Thế
phải tạo nhìn em ạ lại phải mất công tạo
nhiều bà cũng như là viết
viết khá nhiều
Ừ chứ khi ở kiểu em em chỉ không nên
dùng Pocket khi mà nó không hỗ trợ được
cụ thể cái bài toán của em còn về cơ bản
bát ít đây là nó hỗ trợ phải 78 mới phần
trăm những cái kế toán chỉ hội chết rồi
cho mình mình sẽ phát một tí có có tự
nhiên ai gọi E
không
bây
[âm nhạc]
giờ mình sẽ sáng lên file bài này
nhà
mình có bảo ngủ giờ này ai đi đúng không
Tôi thực ra là đang chỉ muốn à
Xe ga có thể lưu lại cả Avatar nữa được
thì mình sẽ không Avatar ở đây tự lái xe
mà ta thì lại phải làm cả tính năng
chỉnh sửa thông tin cá nhân thôi cũng
được
mình sẽ có đấy thấy bồ này
nên này
nói chuyện chứ nói chính Nên này này
sẽ có Avatar
bài
làm đơn giản thôi Nó là kiểu chia ra làm
à Kiểu admin là Superman cũng được hoặc
là kiểu nói chung là chỉ làm Muốn tương
đối thôi Nó kiểu cấp độ ấy lấy vụ như
này chứ giờ mình 057 toán thuốc ta vội
ừ ừ
Nghe
tiếng hát cốt thẳng luôn cái quyền ngồi
ta thấy cậu đã admin được phép và đâu
Chúc em đi được phép và đâu chị ạ Chứ
mình không không làm để nỗi phức tạp
kiểu cực kỳ phức tạp với cả và kiểu dạng
là về sau có thể trình sửa quyền của một
người nào đó cái đấy nó phức tạp hơn
ở một mình sẽ còn thêm cái gì nhà mình
sẽ có thấy bồ Trinh này sẽ có email
biệt với amin là Superman thôi Bởi vì
đây trang của tôi ra cái cái này ra ngát
đây mà đấy
hôm trước dậy năm tôi không muốn trong
dp rồi sẽ Hạn chế dùng ý năm mua và dùng
kiểu y dùng kiểu buôn lần không nên dùng
năm nữa
trước ý ở ông cố định cố định sẽ không
ngờ thay đổi cài tốc độ thì còn được
chị
Ừ Ok Lúc đầu mình chắc thế này thôi
ở Sao Đỏ mình tạo cho mình chả yên xuất
chai vào trong máy bay cũng được
số
một này là áp suất kết hợp chất thực ra
là Tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông ấy vụ là Nếu
giả sử Nếu giả sử em chỉ muốn đưa lại là
người đầy đã đăng ký vào lúc nào không
quan tâm người đấy đã đã kiểu đã
dọn ngờ đã cập nhật vào lúc nào thì làm
nhà ở đây rồi chỉ cho nha à
Ừ
thì là ship cho chuẩn để mà mình về cho
mình đẩy cốc lên là người khác inbox Về
thì người ta đỡ phải in Phước bằng tay
nữa lại chạy đôi thôi Cái gì nhỉ à
Em
nhầy bác ít lâu sau
này à
em đi xuống Tại sao ở đây đi Kinh zipper
vào máy bay sân nhà
Em
nói đi không nó nằm trong bây giờ cạn
hình ảnh 523i này à
So sánh kém mình sẽ có cái cột Ví dụ ở
đây mình Tôi đang tìm đã tôi sẽ có khái
niệm đây
có
vào nha
Ừ
nếu nắm tay mặc định có chữ S này là hai
Cụt 2 cột à
cả dưới tấn ap tật
a a
Đây có
Em
nói sao
có người chăm sóc chưa
em vừa rồi che tem xe nóng ở đâu nhỉ
I
love Apple này lại có cái thăm xem bình
thường đây này
Tại sao lại dùng sunfat Hồi trước tôi
chỉ mày ông dùng hết mà ông trùm tham
thế campaign là gì em xem là nói số đó
là số số dây bắt đầu từ
mùng 1 tháng 1 năm 1970 đến thời điểm
hiện tại tại sao lại chúng ta phải dùng
số dây kiểu như hai tại du lịch sử giờ
tôi sẽ có là chỉ lại biết thật à
thế này Tại sao chúng ta ở cấu tạo một
cột ở tham.tap em lại theo kiểu số dây
nó khó nhìn ra nó hơi khó nhìn khi mà
nhìn trong dp rất là khó nhìn Tại sao
mình làm như thế để mở khi mà mình muốn
convert muốn biến đổi cái này ra một cái
khác một cái khác thì ông đỡ phải mất
công format ông ngoại phải bình thường
ấy khi mà giả sử ông lưu lại là ngày
tháng năm như thế này đâu ạ Ông không đi
lại số rồi không Ông muốn con vớt ra
kiểu dạng là năm tháng ngày như thế này
thôi
em thậm chí còn giờ phút giây nữa là xử
thế ông muốn thì con bất từ đây sang đây
rồi em ạ Ông vẫn phải mất công thêm một
cái đoạn mà không phải biến cái này
thằng đối tượng nói chung là nó mất công
hơn tiền nó đánh đối tượng cho mấy con
con vất lại còn nếu một khi ông đã có
cái kiểu đó là tham Xem sẵn rồi đấy thì
ông không cần phải được Ông không cần
phải Pho Mát gì nhiều ông chạy thẳng
được luôn ông dùng làm pho mát không có
mát luôn cái con số sàn xe mấy thành mọi
cái thứ nó tiện hơn rất nhiều đấy còn
nhược điểm thì ông xem trên database thì
ông sẽ nhìn thấy số lượng ra hơi khó
phải đọc nhiều Tiện đây ạ Ừ ok ở đây là
tôi nói rồi nghỉ ngơi Tôi chạy thử cái
này nhau Bây giờ tôi tạo sinh đôi chỗ
lại nhá Tạo sister để chạy hai cái không
Lúc đi anh như thế thì ra tôi tặng mua
đồ tôi sẽ tạo và
em vừa rồi mẹ không tiện tạm mua đồ nhỉ
Không sao tạo bộ được
thì sẽ pp
này make
Mua đồ là u rô này mình sẽ có là mình
không có controller đoạn này tôi sẽ hạn
chế thịt gà không còn tâm cho l là con
cho lũ sơ tôi không thêm mới ở đoạn này
đâu bởi vì đấy Ăn Nhìn cái gì đó tính
sau mình à
thì mình sẽ ghi lại toàn bộ những cái
cần thêm đi chứ đơn là ghét thì phải
làm gì nhé
Em thích đo mua đồ
10 di quét thì cả ơi chắc thế này rồi
ở
quê farina
phải sự thêm chữ s nữa
chị
đánh festaria
ở Pháp Paris
hay đúng nhỉ
Ừ ừ
đúng rồi à
m là mai mai ơi Chuẩn rồi tôi tôi tạo
Mai ơi chồng nói Tôi không muốn bạn nữa
chị
sẽ còn lên là avatar không ạ
khi nêm
Ê bà đưa Zip speaker
ca
a
tiếp theo ở Avatar này
một ngày giữa hai tôi từng nói hôm trước
rồi tôi cho mấy ông xem cái vụ cấp Cây
Kơ Nia nó thì tạo ra được anh
chẳng có cái ảnh mà
A gọi là đẹp có lắm đâu nó chưa ảnh kiểu
ghi các con số trên đấy thôi inmate này
à
Ừ
Nó remix đây nói này
em đổi sau vậy
Ừ tôi biết rồi trai rauxanh đấy
em
thế
ở
nhà mình như dùng hà Mày
đợi tao một tí nha Tí gọi thằng này gọi
được không
à à
anh hỏi thằng lên được ấy
bộ truyện ngắn
à Tôi nghĩ là có khuya à không gọi được
áo len này
Anh remix
Em
email Google gọi được mà
em
Ừ rồi level không ạ
anh
phi cơ poland
a
tiếp theo email
anh không biết này có bắt tốt không Cũng
có đấy có
ca nhạc trữ tình tích cực thực là nó đơn
giản nó là Nam
vì thế thời gian hiện tại rất hay của
lazaro thì phải lao này nào này nó sẽ cổ
Converse và Mọi cái để mày Insert được
gọi cho ông ông ông
kiểu trong đây ông cần truyền à là tham
nè hay là hay là đết là hai cái gì đó
dùng hàm nào được đấy tôi nhớ thế tôi
chưa thử
bữa nay bị lỗi tí mình gửi lại biết có
ship đồ
anh đã phải chạy đây xong mới gian so
với này cơ nên thôi là tôi 8 tháng luôn
nhé xuất khẩu giờ đây là Tạo
ừ ừ
anh giờ đây mình tạo là 10 bây giờ đi
Ừ
nếu mà chạy độc lập thì ông chạy sister
độc lập được còn bây giờ tôi nghĩ là tôi
thể chạy con bớt lại cũng được về các
bạn gì thì ít nên chạy nhanh p An
My Craft II
anh ạ
ở đây đây mà ông thấy à mặc định nó sẽ
là mặt bị nói thêm cột ap tật do bạn
thân đủ giờ mình không lấy thực chất thì
mình sẽ phải có topic
à à
public hamsters
anh phiêu ra mình sẽ không có cột
em không có đầy đủ hay cụt I
khi
mà thực ra là cái thì ông có thể không
không cần phải mất công điền kể quyết
Tấn này được ông thể cho mặc định
default nó để tới thể sửa lại cho ông xử
ông không muốn Cứ mỗi làm tạo không phải
thêm nào như này là sự như thế thì trong
database không có thể để Phone nó đấy
cũng sẽ người đều vô đây là tham
không không vậy hàm đâu thì phụ nó là
bên đó là
nhanh nhất cũng bận mà một cái bàn đây
này ông ấy ở đây đây đây Phone này ông à
anh ấn vào bên này
Ừ
đợi tí sao ạ
xe ga thẳng máy kéo nó gợi ý ra đây luôn
Kỹ thuật quân sự mất ở đây nó có cái
tham Zone thì gì đó Thắm xem gì đó rồi
không lại với cha rồi
vườn than em
ở đây cũng tham gia Vậy từ nay chỗ này
có ai sẽ ghi như nào cái quần xem kêu
bản chất Nó là một hàm này sẽ phải gọi
thì chọn ngày
lý
do này
cô gái như này cơ
Ừ
ông chuyển full Chạm Tay Vào đây
a password mày mặc định của nếu mà ông
tạo bằng phi cơ nó sẽ mã hóa đấy
Ừ
nhưng mà Ừ nhà em vừa nói kìa kìa mình
không chơi không biết được à Tí mình nếu
thấy mẹ không biết là PQ thật tiền mà
nhật được nghỉ
em
không kể để phụ nào rồi kìa Thì tôi
không tin ở nó chạy được đâu Thì cái này
mới là ấy chạy ạ
em nói chị nhỉ
em gửi nhá Tôi ở chỗ dùng nào rồi nhưng
mà
Ừ cái nào này là cái này bản chất là
mình lưu lại trong đây Baker mà Thử Thử
thì biết
ừ ừ
này nó mình bản chất Mình lưu gì nhé á
anh
Ừ
nếu thể thao đấy không dùng lao trong
trường hợp này Đấy mình sẽ phải như thế
này cơ Nó giống phải tin tôi
thì
nó sẽ làm như thế này này
Em
lý
ờ ờ
a Rolling back
Ý của bác thôi tôi chọn à quét rồi Nhưng
rốt hẳn đấy không phải với phát rồi
anh rất tôn tạo lại này à
à à
và theo thời gian hiện tại
đấy thì password
ở trường là the Gallery tơ thì tôi cũng
không làm cái kiểu như thế này đâu tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ tạo vào trong News Reader này
cách tạo trong hồ sơ thích tôi rồi tôi
chạy đến nó
anh xóa bằng Story đi nhé
Em
muốn xóa nhỉ Có sai đi
Ừ
thì lại nó như này
Ừ thế Hằng đầu tiên tôi vào UC đây
cho tôi sẽ tự đây gần như là
bây giờ này à
Anh thường là tôi sẽ tạo luôn sẵn ở đây
là có hai thằng Không ạ là có
ờ ờ ví dụ được à
ở
Nghe nhạc chờ đợi tôi yêu nha game này
ơi
anh
cơ này là
anh nói cho mày không dùng đồ riết rồi
nha
Anh
Faker là gì được
cô nàng
anh không
em
của nó để cơ Ferry
không thì mình gọi thay đổi gì thôi Lâu
lắm không động này đợi trông tí Đợi tôi
một tí anh sẽ có sister đây đúng không
là tao về quyết định này
trong này suy nghĩ Ven Đô mà chuyên gia
đô mà nếu mà không gọi làm cái cơ đấy
thì ông sẽ phải chạy ra đúng cả ngày cơ
[âm nhạc]
ông phải cài thêm cái thư viện này ông
trùm cái ạ cơ riêng
Anh không dùng được cái hàng VIP hacker
như thằng trăm phạt nhà thằng kia ra
không quan trọng Tôi có thể đặt luôn ở
đây thì đây nó cũng giống nhau thôi tôi
sẽ quyết thẳng đi ăn miến như này à
Ý
thuế Để luôn label đi
được phép đời sống ở level dán mi nóng
lạnh
em không đi
bộ phim heo
Em email này mèo rồi này password này
chồng email giống cô ấy
a password
password ở đây thì tôi cứ mặc định cho
123 Phạm hình gì đã rồi tí sẽ dạy mày
Ông Mười cả mã hóa nữa mình sẽ phải sử
lý nha Cái thật ấy thì không cần mặc
định nói với cô rồi không ạ tạm hội như
thế này mình sẽ có một cái là triệu
ở đây đây là amin cái còn Superman thì
sao mình là mình có thể mình có thể làm
đi cậu ngay à
The Last Time ngay à
ở
đó mình lại ghét thêm thằng nữa
Hôm nay thằng ạ
Ê bà xã Superman này
đi
một ngày à
v-app này đỡ mật khẩu 123 trắng ạ chạy
ngay tại Hà ngay bây giờ một cách cái
clip này nó sẽ luôn khởi tạo đối tượng
thì không ấy không nhớ còn nếu Mấy ông
không muốn làm gì thì khởi tạo được đối
tượng thì mày không nghệ chơi trò là à
gộp hai cái mảnh này làm một số ông chạy
Hà Min shop tại thẻ Insert được rất
nhiều hành cùng lúc còn Kris thì chỉ
được một hàng một lúc thôi
nói gì Tôi muốn gọi thằng
a post này thì mình thấy có lệnh Ở đấy
nó là gọi đến dịp thì ko đúng không ạ
này
Oh shit tắm cái
em hãy thử nhà thử biết ngủ ngon
ở lại à
em
Ừ Ok Đấy nó sẽ chạy thịt đình sheet.new
ship
bên này
khi sex
Anh
ở chị hai thằng thôi chị ạ ta tạm thời
chấm
đó Xô sau đó đi bây giờ mình sẽ làm gì
Bây giờ thì mình cứ thử
Em thử kiểu tạo đầu tiên thì mày Ông
thấy mặc định mình sẽ và đấu tranh mà
mình giữ bình thường vợ vẫn không Nhà
chồng nó chẳng có ai ngăn cản được mình
đấy Tao sợ mình đây à Có khóa học này
vào giữa bình thường thể xóa ở khóa đi
Cái thứ cho ai càng cho mình cả ạ Bây
giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra quyền như thế nào
mình sẽ tạo những từ Word để kiểm tra
quyền đầu tiên là nó tiên là mình sẽ vào
bên router
đi tắm ở đây chắc bữa đi Đợi tí Đợi tí
sẽ ơi này web này
cho tôi sẽ
nhóm tất cả thằng này vào trong một cái
gọi là mới đầu em nữa không cho một khi
mà chưa đăng nhập như thế này không ạ
Mình sẽ không cho kiểu tự tự vào với hệ
vào lên để mà xe mọi thứ ngày giờ đây
tôi sẽ có một cái router kiện nha À khái
niệm giúp là theo nhóm như thế này xong
rồi tôi sẽ
khi sex
Ừ thôi tôi có một cái gì đó một cái mạnh
như thế này tạm thời Thế đã nói chuyện
với anh ạ
hình ảnh
Tống tất cả hàng ngày nói cho tao hả như
thế
vì thế lúc này mình học toán hệ truyền
được rất nhiều thứ ở trong này nhà ông
thế mà nói chuyện được rất là nhiều là
mình sẽ chuyện đây truyền những cái gì
những chuyện và làm middleware như thế
này
Ừ cái quê mình sẽ gọi đến một thằng gì
đó chính là cái thằng mà bây giờ mình sẽ
tạo với ông sẽ thấy là bây giờ cái thư
mục app này http này có cái thư mục và
midwest này và bản chất mà mình đã từng
tiếp xúc của giấy Hồng Beat the weather
rồi nhưng béo nhớ là chị hết hàng sẽ
được em Token này giống nhiều không ạ là
nói kiểm tra cho em làm trong for Sport
của mình có chuyện có quen chưa Không
thì nó sẽ luôn trả về cái lỗi đúng ạ
Mình sẽ tạo ra một thảm midway thì một
nông trại Hàn lệnh make me the way còn
Hồi đấy tôi không biết về lệnh thì tôi
sẽ thương ai lấy cái hàm mặt hàng để
copy rồi trả lời thằng nào đợi được thì
tôi sẽ lấy hàng này
thì tại sao vậy Thằng này nó có cái hẳn
Hanoi xử lý xử lý bài toán ở đây là gửi
Nếu mà có vấn đề gì đó thì điều hướng
quay trở lại còn không thì vẫn cho phép
Tiếp tục chạy như thế này đấy tôi sẽ rất
nhiều tôi copy này
là mấy ông chạy cái hình như có lệnh Hồi
đấy à Tôi nhớ không có lệnh cơ để make
make me the way bây giờ Chắc có rồi
gì
I make the wand
mình sẽ cần kiểm tra ở đây là mình cần
kiểm tra với quyền là tôi tôi đang định
làm bài toán nó là như thế này với
với kiểu dạng là với ạ
a
Superman thì làm được hết mọi thứ chắc
chắn rồi với admin thì sẽ có thể là là
mình một là mình sẽ chỉ cho xem khỏe bên
này tí nhé Một là mình sẽ chỉ cho xe làm
bên làm việc với sư đơn còn bên A khóa
học này cái thứ gì sẽ không cho truy cập
chẳng ngại là sư Thế là sự dễ hay là
thực ra là admin ta vẫn để xem mình tất
cả hàng ngày không ạ nhưng mà không
không được quyền để vào bên xóa là Nhạn
đấy cả hai hàng ngày thằng thoảng admin
sẽ không được vào quần xóa lạ thì tôi sẽ
làm nha Thì bây giờ mình sẽ có một cái
chết log in vào một cái là check
Superman
sẽ có một cả chết cho we
did when i khi sex ở nhà
kỹ đó là đây một cái rất hay đó Lara nào
luôn Chạy qua mọi file của nó thao ngày
Facebook với và nó sẽ chạy vượt qua mọi
vai bây giờ mấy ông thấy à Rõ ràng là
tôi chạy cái sớm ở đây này mấy ông Nghĩa
nó chẳng ảnh hưởng gì cốt của ông Út Của
Ông mới hay đang đang kiểu dạng như ai
đang để trống chửi như thế này đang lỗi
mặt cú pháp này ạ Ông nghĩ nó không chạy
đến nhưng không Nó đã chạy qua tất cả
các file rất nhiều file không phải tất
cả nhà nó hơi sai nhưng mà học viên Quốc
và luôn Chạy có rất nhiều file và bao
gồm có cả phải này thì ra nó bị lỗi nên
là bây giờ tôi sẽ phải ẩn đi nha Nếu
chạy được đấy ở
đó có phải tạm được biết the weather có
là bây giờ có thêm lệnh mới rồi đây nó
cũng là hai đồ đúng ạ
mặc định là nó sẽ cho thông qua như thế
này Đấy giờ mình sẽ xử lý nó như thế nào
sẽ kiểm tra nó thì ah
như thế này
mấy ông sẽ nghĩ ra mà tôi thể hoàn toàn
ưu thẳng như này không ạ
từ
ngày đó ạ
có ngon không thường là chúng ta sẽ
không làm thế này chúng ta sẽ có khái
niệm là major beat Where the weather lum
như này
anh không biết ở Hồi đấy có đúng chậm
Nhưng em nha Đợi tôi đợi ông tí gì Như à
Không ai làm cho cậu
tạo như thế này Tại sao với tạo như thế
này nó không
anh
không được rồi bạn ạ
Ừ bắt buộc ở chúng ta sẽ phải tạo một
cái ở đây nữa tôi thường hay tạo thì một
ngày nữa ở đây như thế này
anh
làm sao đội Chỉ có xe máy vụ mới được
qua đã lâu không động mạnh
Nghe danh sách này the weather
có
ai báo khởi tạo các từ thử nhá ngon
cài đặt tên file này là
ở tập Tina
a force mix đồ
v-app Tomato web có thể xử lý trước và
sau này
cô
hết vào trong cài giúp kiểu như này
chồng với nhau mà
ở
Tâm ít được nghe hay à Ô tô mesa Group
Có ai có thể dùng sai rồi Như thế này
được đấy
ạ Và bây giờ cho dùng trai ở đây tôi
toàn dùng trong group coi
từ
ngày tôi sẽ tải một thằng tôi sẽ copy
Thành ngày để tả một dòng sông xong tôi
thường hay dùng kiểu cách đấy hơn
anh
ở đây tôi không dùng kiểu này đâu à
Ừ
bắt thêm webcam
cần nhìn mà tôi làm gì
đây tôi sẽ đặt tên nó là là ăn mini
ảnh mà thằng này nó dễ kiểm tra thêm một
cái là trách
một
ngày sẽ kiểm tra thêm một cái là
A
sex.in Hiện nay tôi hoàn toàn tôi gọi
được nó ở đây như thế này
Ok chưa
Ừ
ở nhà anh Khánh à
ở đấy và bây giờ
ạ bây giờ đương nhiên là cái này nó đang
đang triệu vẫn cho mình thông qua
tắt bớt ở ngoài đấy ạ Ừ nếu không thấy
vào vẫn bình thường phải sao cả Nhưng
bản chất à bê tôi thử acro một ở đây
xong rồi axit em ạ
axis Nó cũng kiểu giống như D Đó là nắp
toàn bộ đằng sau dừng nó cố tại đây
đó thì ông thấy là nó đã chạy chạy qua
tâm lý thói quen này không ạ Đây cách
kiểm tra đấy không không cho
em không cho mấy ông can thiệp tiếp ăn
thịt tiếp là sẽ Cậu chọn lấy cái quét
cho này Bây giờ thì da mình chưa làm thì
đăng nhập ạ Đây mình sẽ thử ít mình kiểm
tra chứ sân là kiểm tra thí sinh kiểm
ngay thôi gọi cùng anh nếu có thể dùng
Cài á
khi con 2 cách gọi của season 1 là ông
dùng kiểu này hai ông sẽ được
đi hẳn chứ sân ngay để ông import cái
này vào kiểu như này tôi thường hay dùng
cái không biết post thì cho
trong một lỗ trống em nghe
Ừ thôi tôi cháu không thích dùng 2 Harry
Potter lắm cái kiểu như thế này thì nó
là hết Thôi nào đeo nó cũng là tương
đương thằng chia đôi không khác gì đã sẽ
kiểm tra đây ví dụ hát ở đây là là có
thể là hát cô dâu này kẹo kiểm tra đăng
nhập thì ở đây mình sẽ kiểm tra chỉ cần
level luôn được
ai kiểu này
các
em à Không có
anh không có thì mình sẽ điều hướng quay
trở lại nữa hả Mình quay trở lại trang
đăng nhập thì direct
có nhiều router
Ừ
phải trả đăng nhập đúng
Vì thế tôi phải tạo đây một cái Trang
đây là
đăng nhập đã
Anh thường là tôi sẽ tạo một controller
chị xử lý vụ đăng nhập đăng nhập đăng
xuất như thể đặt tên nó là vâng
controller được hoặc là nó tin các chợ
được gì tùy
họ thì cần chất lượng của ông không biết
là tôi nói gì thường hay đặt tên nó lót
inventor lâu thì tôi cứ tạo cái
file Word và trả lại nhá mấy
khi sex
Ê con chó này à
à à
Á
Châu Cần Thơ cũng chuẩn
cài
đặt tên Audi mày về sau bạn đã toán liên
quan đến mấy cái được phân quyền cá thứ
đẹp đây được
Ừ anh đừng trêu em mới buồn
anh nói cho đại khái như này với con xin
lỗi này
à à
Anh
ấy ở đây sẽ là
anh
I Found Love
anh ấy
nội y cho
tôi Gõ thỉnh thoảng nó bị sai thì đó
chưa quen cái bàn phím lắm mới mua bàn
phím bàn phím này tôi đang mua là bàn
phím nó nó nhỏ hơn là kín cũ khá nhiều
vì tôi muốn cậu Cái con laptop mới này
của tôi cũng mua rất là gọn nhẹ và bàn
phím rất gọn nhẹ để mà vì sao mình đem
đi di chuyển có thứ về sau muốn máy khỏe
rồi tôi sẽ đi một con sợ PC mà ăn Mày
tình cây sau đó
bộ phim
gì vậy tội chẳng biết nó xúc gì à Nó là
một bàn phím cơ giá rẻ thôi
2009 người con cũ nó bé gọn nhẹ
Ừ anh đợi nó sẽ chuyện với ông theo Bây
giờ cứ vào bất kỳ đâu Với ai sẽ đều
hướng quay trở lại đấy đây như bên này
mình đang chưa làm gì cả Đây mình sẽ ghi
tên về một cái view chỉ liên quan đến á
đăng nhập thôi thường là đấy nó là gợi ý
rất là hai này mình sẽ có một số mục
liên quan đến au hợp lý mình sẽ có mấy
thư mục Đoài
hình
ảnh Sony Cái ở có wi-fi là
Lê Ngọc Kim
a template
ppt ê
anh
chẳng biết hãng gì hay không nổi lắm đâu
anh ờ
Ừ cái này thì thực ra bổ vỉa Hồi trước
và mình ôm cái tem led kìa hyper về
không nhiều không ạ
thì mệt với ông hệ hoàn toàn lấy cái
giao diện đấy
Ừ cái dòng điện have đội bay rồi
Ừ
rồi đi
ở nhà máy này chưa Tôi chưa tải cái
anh ở đây
Ừ vậy thì kéo dài nhé
cho
nông dân đi
em hết hot đã chuẩn bị nhảy đến router
là
in a
làm thẻ nó là động từ
cũng rất là hay
Em Hát Cho đẹp cái gì quan trọng gì đẹp
ở đây
kiến thức rồi xấu xấu nó đôi khi lại đỡ
giật đa cấp
à À đây mình phải email nhé email này à
ở hà email name email tiện phết
a
phim hài
a password mềm password with
đúng ở mấy cái rồi được làm nhiều đề
xuất chuẩn nó hơi này
ờ ờ
30 chưa khai báo cái mô tơ đúng ạ cho tơ
này mình sẽ mình sẽ làm nó cho nó sẽ nằm
ngoài nó biết là quen ngồi trước đã có
ông biết sử cái này vì trong cơ bên
trong mí thói quen này chỗ chưa đăng
nhập thì đều hướng về cái trang đăng
nhập nhưng cái sao nhập lệnh nằm trong
phải đăng nhập rồi hai nó vòng là Thùy
Dung treo luôn máy đấy mấy ông cố chạy
được đấy nhé
anh chạy xe post này Cái vẫn có thể cùng
với ai thôi em nói rất là nói cái này
trở lại nó phối xác Nói nó ạ
Tôi muốn xem
anh nói này cách viết ở đây sẽ phố xét
anh nói nặng
ừ ừ
JAV HD với anh
điền dụng là
admin@gmail.com đó thì mật khẩu là có
đúng đã nhá là 123
bấm lõi là này mình sẽ tạo cái Hàn này
thì
mình sẽ tặng với ha Nó thích tăng sinh à
hai
tay mẹ sẽ nói Im ngay
thì mình sẽ lấy
đi quét
Anh
số 1 là ông vay đét cũng được không
virus đoạn này tôi hôm nay vậy nha nhưng
tạm bỏ qua vụ vay biết có gì với ông
phải đến sau nhá
Tôi sẽ lấy à
ở đây tôi sẽ lấy cái
số người dùng về đô Rio de bằng Urê này
khi Harry
cho gọi đến que
Em email
vì
vậy Ngon phết nhỉ à
Ừ thôi Tôi ghét kiểu dùng cho bằng được
tôi dùng thẳng luôn chỗ này cơ
a
password password này
em
Ừ Ok ai
ở
của nó thì nhớ tôi từng nói với ông rồi
nó sẽ bắn về exception nếu mà là sử
không tìm thấy thằng nào thì mình sẽ
xoay cát ở đây rồi dậy mà ông khái niệm
luôn chai cát mình sẽ mình sẽ chai là
mình sẽ thử một cái gì đó như thủ tán
gái ạ xong rồi cát ở đây là là bắt các
trường hợp đều bắt Trường hợp nếu mà một
tỉnh ông ở đây là 60 bồ như thế này là
bắt mọi trường hợp bao gồm cả lỗi lô gic
về lỗi của phát nó sẽ nhờ vào đây một
cái tướng đồn đó nha Có vài lỗ của Pháp
thì khi biên dịch à ở tp nào lỗi hỏng
luôn thì nó không thể lấy đâu xử ông
thiếu chấm phẩy anh thế này là đôi khi
nó không để đây đâu em có rất nhiều lỗi
khác thì nó sẽ nhảy vào đây nhờ khi ông
Toàn cái ta cũng họ lỗi lầm bằng sẽ nhảy
đây trở lại thêm sự xử lý gì thì ông có
thể hoàn toàn là điều hướng quay trở lại
kèm thêm cái lỗi
ở
thêm một cái gì đó mày không nhiều không
ạ Cái
em
còn đây trong trường hợp nếu đúng thì
sao mình sẽ Mình sẽ lưu lại trong sân
tôi chưa dùng lao vậy thôi chị làm cái
khuôn thôi sẽ lưu lại thí sinh mình sẽ
là lưu lại phút thí sinh này
khi mình thừa mình không cần lưu lại
email ở trong thí sinh sẽ lưu lại là
mình sẽ lưu lại đi người anh đăng nhập
này
ông bà với một sớm thế
a
sao mình cần mình cần là mình ý mình có
thể sử dụng liên tục avatar của chị ra
người dùng thực a
người dùng khi mà vào đăng nhập vào
người ta sẽ luôn nhìn avatar đã cả tên
của họ trên ike và bạn chất mình sẽ luôn
lưu lại những cái điều đấy nên này
em nói chuyện nghe
nói điều hướng quay về thường là tôi sẽ
điều hướng quay về trong welcome nhưng
mà đây tôi không có trang Web Cam ấy tôi
cứ mặc định là là Trang Trang này nek
nhé
ừ ừ
tuổi xem lại phim Bấm ở đây vì nó không
quen được bàn phím lắm mà ông thấy tôi
gọi chậm hơn phạm ký
anh em báo lỗi thế à
ở Hà Nội Kệ ông ta không gặp
anh ơi
ý
định chuyển về kệ không tin à
a good là đẩy ra còn phút là phút là đẩy
vào và tôi nhớ không làm mình bị lỗi nếu
trong trường hợp mà đã có giá trị lấy
rồi còn phút là bạn đặt vào theo kiểu
lại nếu mà có ra sự có cái thang này
trong đấy rồi nó sẽ ghi đè lên đấy à
có
à à quên quên quên quên
Lê
Hiếu cái ông biết tại sao nó quay lại
vẫn quay trở lại biết đâu nhưng không vì
mình quên chưa có cái level nhảy
ạ
não quá em tôi nói gì vậy đấy
anh
không đúng không phải ví dụ mà tôi chưa
dùng ao thật tôi chưa Rủ nhau với chồng
chưa Dùng cái đấy chứ cái ao chưa dùng
cái Pocket tôi tôi chưa dùng lên tôi
chưa dám Vậy thôi heo tôi mà chắn trên
cái đấy giờ tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông nhờ Nếu
mà nói qua tốt Nó quay Vũ Xuân luận được
tốt mà sao
Em về đây đi đó nhiều người không thấy
phải sửa lại và ta ở đây tên ở đây không
phải định đúng tên mình không ạ thì mình
sẽ bên À cái này nhiên nằm trong Clow
vậy
bên
bên hết đồ
sửa lại tên
từ
lúc đào này ok
anh em ở Quốc đảo nào đó
ở ngã tư đốt tao đi
Vì sao tay phết nhỉ
em
không cho
để lại phần mở sau khi tất nhiên rồi cậu
nhỉ
ừ ừ
Are You Now out
Em đâu rồi
Anh
ấy chạy chậm đi À đây
có ai đóng Đây xóa đây
lại phải đi thuê
có
ai nữa không quan trọng Đấy đóng xóa đây
ở
Hà Nội
rau cắm xuất tinh lock out đã để lại cái
này
mình có sốt không nhỉ
em gái
Ừ
vào đây thì chị ra thôi cảm ơn
Ơ hay
Ok Good For You
Em
có chị này thôi Nó đối đúng ạ Đây này
mình sẽ chạy tên là Đây này xin
like rồi đấy mình sẽ đây bà
Bởi vì tôi chưa cài cài đặt biết về mày
không phải ngon hơn
tôi cái
anh ạ
read này
Ừ cái hết về cho bé uống xem nhé ngon
luôn
biết hay tơ này
em ngồi Blade
ở đây nè
mình nha
xe Blade
cứ mấy cái đầu tiên chơi hết toàn bộ cái
đầu tiên à
Xem phim sex online
em tắt đi mở lại
bài
đấy
có mình sẽ có season II
khi họ
A Z
Ừ để nêm
Ừ cái này sẽ à Đi vụ
ông ngoại
về giá rẻ nhược điểm level nhà mình sẽ
phải chia trường hợp đó là
à à Superman
à à Tôi chưa cập nhật Cái qua cho mày
Ừ
xe ô tô ghi cái này nha nha không thể
sửa lại cái gì của khác nha nó
cô giáo sư gái đi
mình phải thì Avatar ở đây mình chưa có
chưa có nên cho anh định đi k a
ông
amin à
thấy cố tình nói qua với vest buồn với
anh
anh cũng gỗ em đâu à OK thì con cái gì
nhỉ
khu
vực trung tâm đổ như thế này thì mấy ông
sẽ thấy à tôi copy được lên này
vào ẩn ra nhưng mà ông thấy yêu cầu lông
nhật vì rõ ràng là chưa đăng nhập gì cả
Không ạ Còn bây giờ thì đăng nhập rồi
nếu không thể xem ở trong nhà cái đi gấp
ba này thì sẽ thấy trong sinh mình có có
thí sinh mình còn lưu lại cái thứ trong
thích thân với ai lại cho tiện chỉ nó có
cái mí từ que ra ngoài được này
trong này nó có ghét hay mấy chục cái gì
đó cơ nhưng không Tớ ở đây
thông qua hai giờ biết thử que
webgame in thông qua web-8000 này ra à
cho tôi khi tôi xóa cứ vậy á ở bên này
đi được tôi chỉ có mỗi cái này đâu không
nhỉ
Anh bảo làm thông qua web mà tại sao
mình phải gọi tận hai thằng nhỉ
Ừ ừ
con bé ông không tầm cái này vào đây lâu
nha tổng cái này vào đây còn phải đăng
nhập mấy ông cũng yêu cầu đăng nhập
ừ ừ
thế thì có khi không cần phải làm dạo
này đâu không cần phải tạo giúp mới ngay
đâu cũng chích thẳng luôn đấy ngay à
ở thời tiết thế Làm dạo này thì đơn giản
hơn
ông chủ nhật thôi nha tự tử
Ừ rồi đấy à Hồi tôi dùng ở tận level 5
chấm với nó không có kiểu như hai em
không biết
Ừ
anh Thủy Tại sao không lỗi này mở ẩn ra
nhà đó ngon ngọt ngon đấy Tại sao thì
thấy là nó sử dụng hai cái Ok ok Thế thì
nếu ở trong trường hợp mà ông chỉ có cần
1 lít được về cho nó cái nhìn này gọi
cái này cho nhanh đỡ phải đỡ phải khai
báo ở trong Canon để mà tạm một mic
Facebook nữa được à
An
nhà
đất phúc chính là cái này đấy Yêu mà sao
tấm cái chết nói nói cho nghe
Ừ
ok
rồi tôi nói qua mày không phải biết được
nghe và đăng nhập Thế bây giờ còn tạo
thêm một cái midwest nữa là để kiểm tra
nếu trong trường hợp là là kiểu Xóa
Thằng hạn thì thì sẽ phải thêm nóng ạ
Em
Cô Bơ ăn Minh đã nhắm được tài ở dễ hiểu
nha à
trò
chơi Superman
nhà sản xuất đã chuẩn bị đang xuất với
ẩn danh mà ông ấy có ngay cái gì nó suốt
à
Ừ nếu ông thư da bạn đoạn này thì kiểm
tra là dễ thôi bởi vì mình bản chất là
mình cần kiểm tra ở chỗ nào Chỗ này thì
ra vì chuộc này mình sẽ phải thêm một
cái là
So sánh bỏ quá đi cho này ngay tại sao
mà mình sẽ tạo thêm một cái thằng router
giúp nữa
cài
đặt tôi đã đi cái thả Thằng Đô Tao giúp
nữa
Anh ở người cùng đi
một
ngày sẽ là trách
về Superman
[âm nhạc]
- the West
3nana đó
ở đó
hai bà ngày sẽ có lô tô
các bạn này hơi thủ công một tí thường
lần thứ ba về xong nếu không dùng vì
suốt ngày đâu
con gà làm công ty ông Toàn lại đi đầy
đủ lao công ty tôi xuống hay không dùng
hết đây sẽ là Delete này
đi later sau đây sẽ ra
a cost
Xóa ID đó anh sẽ đi trôi
hình ảnh có
đi chơi tương tự thế với à
Chứ đừng thôi
Ừ từ đình tôi đình
đi soi này và ngày cũng sẽ loạn đi cho
ra nhưng ai đó
Ừ cái thử nhỉ Bây giờ đang là đăng nhập
admin đúng không ạ Cho tôi thử Ánh xóa
xóa đâu nha À quên quên và xóa được Đấy
mình đã kiểm tra rồi không lấy kiểm tra
này để kiểm tra là nó chứ Xuân
à à
có nét level
ở
bang bang bang balô bạn đi Nó không chắc
chắn là kiểu nó nó làm nhìn thì mình khi
vi Jack bác không không phải quay lại
trang nữa không phải quay lại trang
đăng nhập đây nhá Mình chỉ cần kiểu quay
lại thôi
anh quay lại không không cho làm thịt à
nha không thể kèm 2 cái lỗi được
I miss đá
xe lửa đã đi hôm nay
à À quên quê
Ừ cái À cái này mình nghệ đang dùng ipad
nên thành ra là không
anh không không cần điều hướng gì cả em
ạ
cho mình mình không điều hướng được đoạn
này vì mình đang dùng ánh mắt để xử lý
nhà tôi tôi thử tôi thử để nó là kiểu
dạng là bỏ ra đây nhá Tôi tạo bỏ rác đi
điều hướng cho bé ông ta mãi nhé Rồi tôi
á
em
đã bỏ đi này BN có này không biết
I love
chỉ cần nút này hồi đấy nó là nút là bất
cần tôi đổi nó nút anh mất đừng nên
thành ra là à
xe đạp đua đòi
ở đây hay cuối tuần mẹ nó không dám ít
nhưng mà
nó sắp ít như này cho nó thì bỏ cái cái
đoạn cô này đi khi bấm với nó sẽ sắp với
phom thì sẽ như thế nào
anh
bấm mày đó mày Ông thấy nó quay trở lại
thằng một nó vẫn chưa bị xóa đúng không
ạ Mày không thấy thằng một nãy giờ chạy
đi chạy lại nhưng nó cũng sợ xóa không ạ
Đấy và B nếu trong trường hợp mà giờ sự
ông muốn dùng gấp mà xử lý nếu như cái
bosston không cho chấm bi form đoạn này
ông sẽ xử lý gì ông sẽ cầm ném một cái
lỗi ở đây
Bắn về một cái lỗi gì đó để nó sẽ và ông
sẽ xử lý ở trong Alo Này ấy ông thế à
đây sẽ là thường dâu
anh như này đâu anh Xuân hoa cà
sau đi Sầm Sơn à
Nhớ
Ừ
đợi tao tí
u sầu notation
nhớ có phím tắt thế mà làm bộ này
à à
ở lại Sony expansions
có
anh nghe cảnh báo tôi trong thường em
sao
đi
lên so với sẽ chuẩn hay nói lên như nào
nữa thử thử nhé
ở
đây nó sẽ bắn về một cái là
à à
Anh không được làm thế ạ ạ Dừng lại đi
đừng anh ngủ ngon Anh cứ hết
anh
nghe cái địa chỉ
sản phẩm này
ông
bây giờ bấm vào đó nó sẽ bạn với lỗi 500
này và trọng tâm xô nó sẽ nhảy vào Alo
không ạ
ở
đây thì hoàn toàn không thì xử lý ở bên
A bên Euro này ông làm đi về đâu là đây
được có tôi sẽ dậy Nếu không phải đa
ngôn ngữ nữa Cái này nó là cái lô kết
lâu cái gì đấy
Climb Racing video này tôi sẽ dậy người
hôm sau
Ừ cái đấy Đúng là cũng nhưng mà ít áp
dụng ví dụ trong đồ ăn hay của mấy ông
được cả nó chỉ có tiếng Việt hoàn toàn
thôi không nói dụng làm gì cả tao diện
mấy ông đồ ăn hay nói tiếng Việt nhé Có
thể cốt mấy ông ấy cố tiếng Anh bản
tiếng Anh nhưng mà nó hiện lên tiếng
Việt với mấy ông chương trình Tiếng Việt
ngồi tôi ngồi đọc Nếu hết lưỡi tiếng Anh
trong buồn cười lắm ý
ờ ờ
khi con gì nhỉ Đấy vừa rồi tôi đã nói
qua cho mấy ông cảm thấy thích sân cả
biết được nghe đấy còn sao nói gì mấy
đúng rồi đúng rồi ông bà ấn nút đi đúng
không không hiển thị nút thì nó đơn giản
mà mình sẽ kiểm tra thôi kiểm tra đúng
Bạn nói đúng đấy anh sẽ ẩn đi
Ừ nhưng mà anh nghĩ ở đây thì ra mày
không thấy có nhược điểm là đi nó cũng
hơi phải sử dụng vào nhiều chỗ anh sẽ
yêu chỉ mấy ông nếu dùng là mau chóng
nhận kịch đoạn code này nó cho mà ngắn
hơn tao ấy chỉ như này thôi đấy kiểm tra
đã như nào đó nhưng mà
ở đâu Nó không kiểm tra được level 2
nghe mình vẫn lại chơi rồi nha
mà bằng bằng 1 thì mình mấy thì chị ra
cái này chắc lại
em ít à
Ê mấy ông có một sự thật là mấy ông nghĩ
cái này pp đúng không Nhưng thực ra cái
này nhúng bất kỳ động được nhúng nó
xuống cả bên A
bên ta Swift trở lại được này
cho
dù nó cách báo này Kệ nha
em
ở
đó mất nút chưa Ok chưa Không có nút thì
sẽ không chuyển bấm nhầm đúng không ạ
Ừ ok chưa ạ
ờ ờ
khi sex đề thi ở đây mày không thấy cái
đoạn này ra cứ lập Điệp lại nó hơi khó
chịu một tí nhưng giờ tôi sẽ chỉ luôn
cho ông thêm một cái nữa Nếu không thấy
vừa rồi tôi còn nói qua vụ hepl làm chỉ
là cái thằng này chứ Xuân Này bạn rất là
nó sẽ inbox hộ mình cái À cái thư viện
Xuân để mà lấy dữ liệu thì cái này gọi
là hàm hết tơ tất cả hàm này hấp ơi tất
cả trợ giúp mẹ nó sẽ dùng ở mọi chỗ và
nó sẽ gọi hàng về ngay mà mình hoàn toàn
thì phạm cái Hà Thế mà check admin Nội
trước Super beam kiểu như thế mà mình sẽ
gọi mọi chỗ tôi chỉ muốn gọi cảm nha
Trách Superman
ngay gọi đấy nha nó trả về chùa phone cả
ngày càng lạ làm như thế nào Thì bây giờ
mình phải tạo cái file hepl riêng mình
đấy này mình sẽ cần cha crest Hair
gel này nó gợi ý cách để mà tạo ra một
cái file hepl gì đó Anh thường hả Mình
đây
tôi sẽ đặt tên file Happy is luôn như
này được đấy à
Anh
thường là tôi sẽ vứt ở trong thư mục áp
ở trong áp này luôn là nên có cốt của
mình
Cách tạo file hepl
làm tt đó là trong này đứng ở trong này
cốt và
cho hỗn hợp pp rồi ông ạ
ở đó tiếp theo là mình sẽ có khái niệm
này Tại sao lại phải có cái hàng này tồn
tại ở vì cái file này đôi khi nó sẽ được
lót Nhiều lần em mình chỉ cầm kiểm tra
là phương trình này tồn tại được lót cho
hiểu mình không cần nói lại không khởi
tạo lại file trên này nữa nói chuyện này
như tôi vừa bảo nó sẽ ra trách Superman
không ạ Chị sẽ là tên là Trạch
amin này ngay
ở đó
anh xóa y chất là mình sẽ chỉ cần trả về
chua phone là truyền vào nó là
em kiểm tra xem hài
anh có đúng hay sai ngay
Xóa bớt đi này ở đây Rẽ trả về bulan mà
đúng hay sai này đó nếu mà ông tạo như
này xong rồi cũng chưa chạy đâu đấy Làm
nào không phải có thêm cái file này vào
trong cái autolock là cứ chạy cứ khi nào
chạy cái chạy cốt thì nó sẽ loát thêm
cái file ở đó ở Nếu mình chung không thì
nó sẽ nằm trong cái không bao giờ này
xe ô tô lát này truyền thêm em sẽ cho
thêm một cái gần gọi thêm cái file này
máy này của mình là
Thế
objective ở nhà à
xe tải ta phải chạy băng băng tôi lót
Tức là sao nghĩa là bởi vì nó từng nát
hết tất cả đúng ai rồi mà nó không trả
lại cái ô tô bác này đâu thì ông sẽ phải
trả lại cái này đó
ở nhà tắm
dễ ngã Cốc Cốc Cốc à
vì cuộc sống mà đi Cốc Cốc
hình
ảnh xóa hết cái cái rất là tiện ở điểm
là thằng nào đôi khi nó lưu lại cách lưu
lại tất cả cách video mời ông bản chất
là cái thằng Blade này Blade này nó Nó
là một cái kiểu để nó hỗ trợ để mà để mà
ông cốt cho pp nhàn hơn đúng không Rồi
nó sẽ
A journalist và trật tự sinh ra Coast P
và nói lưu cách lại cái đoạn nó đã xử lý
nằm trong toilet này làm trong Facebook
cách này
Nghe nhạc Đây đây đây không phải rất
nhiều pha ngay
nó sẽ kiểu ví dụ là bạn của ông nó sẽ
biến anh kiểu ngay cả nạn đó nó tạo rất
nhiều cái file kiểu ngay nên là có những
lúc mà mấy ông sửa có có trường hợp là
mấy ông sửa sửa cốt rồi tự nhiên không
phải lại xa không được Bởi vì nó đang
lưu cách thì mày ông có thể là tại sao
Google hôi Ly Cách view lao chẳng hạn
đấy nó sẽ kí hộ cho
em trả lại nhé
có ai trả lại vẫn thế rồi Mình đã dùng
hàn kia không tôi sẽ đổi cái chỗ những
cái chỗ dùng hàn để nha thay vì dài dòng
ngay đúng không mà về sau quan trọng vì
sao mà sửa nhỡ đâu không phải là vòng 1
lên 2 R3 thì mình chỉ ảnh hưởng của chỗ
thôi
ở Đông thấy nó không báo lỗi nữa gửi nó
đã chạy được qua cái hàm răng trên này
rồi
Thông Minh Trị
kết quả nhiều lúc cốc hơi chạy được
ở
đó không phải bấm lạ nhanh hay lại kiểm
tra ngon tại sao không thấy thức ăn nó
vẫn thế vẫn thế nhưng mà về sau ông sẽ
xử ông phải tạo rất nhiều file An rất
nhiều hàm Happy Birthday thì ông gọi mọi
chỗ có thể ra diện
hai đội hôm nay ga Tôi vừa rồi nói qua
thêm cả mục hepl Bạn hãy tìm thấy kim
thoảng tôi sẽ nói thêm một vài cái nữa
sức khỏe Chị Mỗi cái trong tiêu đề không
ạ
Ừ
nếu còn thắc mắc gì mà nãy giờ nói có bị
bé quá khó hiểu thì gì đó em
I Delete hay update fast khác gì nhau
không à
Ừ đúng rồi Cái phốt với ghét nó là chị
ra chị Mỗi thế hôm qua nó phân biệt cái
delete và
pass kia để mà chuyện hơn một cái mới
hết nữa để cho nó gọi là bảo không hạt
bảo mật mà nói chung một cái rạch ròi
hơn thôi
từ
không có bấm được
cái này cũng làm nhiều rồi
đi
tôi có dậy mày không log log tao thì đơn
giản thôi à
em cứ nói qua bột lắc tao đi
I not out gì à Một là ông thể đẩy nó
ngay ở trong cái Mỹ được quen này hay
ông Tống ra ngoài được không trọng tôi
cứ để nó bên trong nhá mình sẽ có rorwa
đây này
ở nhà tại mày phải đăng nhập rồi tao mày
cho mày đóng rất đúng không gì hết
mình sẽ sửa lại cái đường link bấm vào
knockout ở bên Là Sợi Tơ
a nhớ rồi đấy có cái nút bấm la tao thì
ra là không bấm được đâu Mai con tinh
này sport này thì bode
a
doctrine study này là log out không thấy
nó lên thẻ trong ngày đi đâu trong bấm
được
bởi mức đâu em mình sửa lại của bạn này
chính sẽ nhảy đến cá rô tơ
là lockout không ạ
ở đó
Ô chết rồi mình bấm vào đây để Lotte
cho mình sẽ
anh
Vi
phạm văn sinh là log out
em
cứ Ca là cái đoạn này chuyến giả là mình
anh ở đây là ra bởi vì mình không Không
làm thì nhiều thì mình có thể là Plus
Xóa hết toàn bộ đi cũng được nhưng không
lưu lại trong sân kiểu những cái gì ở
phức tạp theo kiểu là cũng trước và làm
rõ hàng nó cứ
Ừ ừ thì nó hỗ trợ hết rồi mình chẳng cần
phải làm gì cả anh còn nhớ gì đấy
ở nhà anh chưa dùng bao rồi không biết à
Ở công ty dùng sẵn rồi anh anh tự động
vào anh không biết
em à Cái này phải điều hướng quay trở
lại nó tôi nói xong ghét nhắn hay lòng
đăng nhập đăng xuất rồi các bạn luôn
Nhắn cái xong rồi ạ mình và lại không
được này cái gì chưa
ở
Em cứ thử em nhớ thế nhưng mà đúng dùng
cho Ken không ạ
còn hôm nay vừa làm được đăng nhập đăng
xuất cho người biết được thêm một tí về
Ừ cái việc là khi truyền dữ liệu vào như
thế này thì mấy ông nha có thể bỏ cái
thăm Sandy có thứ đúng không Không phải
bạn nào cũng có hai cột đấy Ở làm gì đó
Anh
hợp âm
Ừ
nó còn muốn ngồi gần hai tiếng rồi tra
Bộ hôm nay kết thúc đấy nhá mày Ông còn
thi thắc mắc à tôi giờ ra tôi chưa xem
video bụng trước nhớ ghi đâu bữa hôm
trước mày không có vài ông đặt câu hỏi
nữa Nhưng tôi chưa kịp trả lời tôi tổng
hợp về bữa sau trả lời luôn một thể nhé
à
The
One Piece
a passport giờ tôi cũng đang định dùng
cái con nít đấy ra tôi chưa Dùng cái đấy
cũng chưa trả lời ông được gửi sau nhé
Tôi sẽ nghiên cứu các thứ thứ rồi bởi vì
nghiên cứu để dùng nó khác nghiên cứu
phải dậy nè chắc cả tôi phải nghiên cứu
kỹ đã Không mấy ông hỏi câu gì thì tôi
không chơi được thì nó vẫn cười anh chào
các bạn nhé
Kết thúc sớm hai tiếng thôi nhé